I'm a little bit nervous to see what
you're going to choose because it's
gonna be on my body forever
but I am also excited
[Music]
I have 17 tattoos now I have a Gandhi
quote that says live like you will die
tomorrow learn like you will live
forever I have two others of veteran so
I wanted to do something that made me
think of him I was thinking for my next
tattoo I want to get something on my
lower back I've battled a lot with
eating disorders and crippling anxiety
and depression and chronic illness my
life isn't perfect but it's definitely
gotten to a really good place and I also
sort want to combine that to commemorate
my mom why because she's a huge part of
who I am and who I'm becoming and when
she passed it was a really huge turning
point in my life she was able to exhibit
such grace and even the most horrific
situations she was calm and loving and
patient and she saw people not for just
who they were but for whom they could be
she saw the good in everyone and tried
to push them to become better now it's
up to you to pick my tattoo and a tattoo
artist here at body electric is going to
sign something and I am NOT going to see
it until it's on my body so be nice to
me
today I'm tattooing Heather these people
from Internet gave me the idea to do it
so this idea is basically a big wave
made it with a small wave say live you
can break big problems with the small
problems and you make everything more
easy
I feel pretty anxious a little bit on
edge
but I'm also really excited the
best-case scenario is that I will love
it and it will be beautiful the worst
case scenario is that it will be
something that I don't like and I might
have to invest in some laser removal
down the road I'm ready to be surprised
[Music]
well is it sleepy when I get happy
though
[Music]
um maybe something with a starfish
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here there
pretty much done [ __ ] I feel like I'm
gonna be relieved when I see it oh wow
it's beautiful I love it I'm really
relieved I'm super happy I love what it
represents and I really like that that's
the conclusion that the internet came to
given the stories that I told even
though your problems can seem really
huge in comparison with the big picture
they're really not so like it really
represents where I've been in my life
and where I am Thank You internet Thank
You Jacob so much
[Music]
[Music]